HERE INOFAW INRITHE WOMEN IRAN.N
KRRUYESEVEBUDIED, ANAT
ROFFICIAL SAID MANY PE BEEN
-OLD GIRL,COMES AS R UKRAINIAN
NEIGINSOGIST IN LUHANSCIESUKRAIN
FOES ONE VILLAGE
ANONE OFFICIAL SAYRALVE BEEN LIR
IALS BELIEVET POFIE WAS KILLED O
DRHER FAAND HE WAS THE ACTUAL
AT LINSCOTT?OWVELOPMENTS I
KRNITHISRAINIAN
DEFENSE, INTELNCOFFICIUKRAINHASD
THAT AOMT  RS YONEE SHE IVG ER'I
EXNSIONISM WAS THEISS
CE ASST AL P QUESTN
TH ASSESSMDO S
EOVERNMEAYRESPONSIBLE FOR ,
UESTION SH
E ABOUT MADE IT CLEAR THAT
E UNITED STES NOT AWARE
THE SSYHNGOFS  R
D ON THEIR
CE COLLECTED TT SEEM TO BE SOMEI
TARGETEDWA
PREPLANNED, ORD.REMEMB THAT THES
ISHEITUSBYENT AUITABPOLICY OF
NTLY DD VETHE Y NIANS HA
SER TO PSI ZELENSKYY
SAID NBECAUSE WE ARE NOTIMINALF,
AFFAIRINTELLIGENCEOMDASCHIFF A H
EMANATINFROMAS NOTNG